I was talking about last week on the
show people call me up and they go well
I'm deeply in debt on my car because my
other car got totaled no that's not how
that works oh it's the same kind of a
thing you go through the emotions of a
car wreck and your car getting totaled
and the lady that that particular case
you know we all do this stuff and you
just have to guard against this this is
what kills us with our finances but you
know the typical person that calls me on
the air whose car got totaled buys a
more expensive car than they were
driving before it got totaled and they
used the car getting totaled as the
justification to do that or the
rationalization to do that and so this
lady had a ten thousand dollar car she
got a ten thousand dollar check she had
seven thousand dollars which means she
had three thousand dollars in her pocket
and she went about 20 thousand our car
okay and all because our but in her mind
she didn't separate the two things she's
in her mind it was like I had to buy a
car because my car got totaled and
there's just only thousand this is what
I bought it didn't make it there's a
distinction that she doubled the amount
of cars she was driving as a result of
the car wreck and those are two
different things
yes you need to replace the car but in
her case what I would have suggested she
didn't do it obviously she'd called me
afterwards but in her case I would
suggest take the three thousand dollars
and buy three thousand our car moved
down in car and be debt-free in her case
but if you can separate the emotions of
the event that has money around it
and determine from that then what is the
right thing to do why wisdom wise what
is the wise thing to do then that really
helps me because I following the exact
same trap that liz is falling into you
do to the same trap the lady with a car
thing we all fall into that if we're not
real careful because personal finance is
personal and what you drive and where
you live and you know my I've had people
call me upset you know my mother passed
away and that's why I'm $60,000 in debt
I'm like how did your mother did you pay
all her bills how'd you end up $60,000
in debt well we had no way to pay for
the funeral or she King Tut I mean how
did you
60,000 all know the funeral wasn't 60
the funeral was 10
and I went okay so you're $10,000 in
debt because of your mother you paid for
your mother's funeral what's the other
50 oh wow I just I yeah but in their
mind they said I got $60,000 in debt
because of my mother's funeral and it
wasn't your mother's funeral and not
even a sixth of it was the mother's
funeral you see how our minds work how
we tie that together and out of the
bundles so the heart the mouth speaks
and so when you've Lunt these things
together in your in your conversation
with yourself that I have and that you
have you need to be careful with that
you know okay I mean these are two
separate things and when you break them
apart then you'll make much wiser
decisions and it's not to say that Liz
can't move up in house it's possible her
finances will allow that but it let's
say that she's in debt doesn't have an
emergency fund and she still needs to
move because of the potential health
problem for her children yeah I move
protect your baby I'm with that I've
never asked my kids to leave their
grandbaby my grandbabies and in the
situation where I was worried about that
and get out of there be done with it
but that doesn't but don't but move
laterally laterally and you know it's a
really interesting thing
how much do our hopes and our fears
how much do our rationalizations and our
justifications our sense of feeling
trapped versus our sense of being
victorious hopelessness versus hopeful
selfishness versus selflessness how
these things interweave into and somehow
we can make the dumbest math and the
world sound smart in the middle of all
that stuff all of us can and I I'm I'm
chief I've got a PhD in D um B it's why
God makes me teach you stuff every day I
can do the exact same thing and again
there is no harm in moving up in car if
your car gets totaled there's no harm in
Lisbon a better house they keep those
two decisions separate
and don't blame the hire-purchase
on the emotional event blame the
hire-purchase on hey I looked at my
money and my finances and I can actually
have the money and I can afford it oh
then that's an okay cool deal keep them
separate and you'll make better
decisions